good afternoon everyone um I've been
away for a while so I lost track as to
whether we had done the katakia last or
the prayer so I'll be starting with a
prayer I apologize if there people been
tracking I got it around the wrong way
but we'll start with the prayer in In
with the katakia honor and glory to God
peace on Earth Good Will to all people
Lord develop a new heart inside all of
us instill in us your sacred Spirit help
us guide us in all the things we need to
learn today amen please be
seated good afternoon again everyone uh
welcome to uh this month's ordinary
council meeting um it is nice to be back
here after some time off and thank you
to the deputy May uh for stepping in
while I was
away do we have any
apologies there appear to be none uh
conflicts of interest councilor H thank
you your worship there are two items in
the agenda one in the public part and
one in the public excluded that relate
to the district plan um I have a uh
nonfinancial conflict arising with
regard to both and I I will not be
taking part in any discussion or um
resolution o of those items but I will
be available for counselors and my role
as chair of the district plan committee
um to answer any questions they might
have on
process thank you councelor councelor
Dixon thank you worship I follow suit
and I won't be taking part in those two
conversations either and that's not
financial reasons it's yes thank you
councelor councelor
yes I to have a conflict in item one in
the Inc commmittee uh part of the
meeting it's non-financial as well and I
will not be taking part in any
conversation during
that thank you councelor any further
conflicts thank you for bringing those
forward we will go into the confirmation
of minutes uh so first up we have the
confirmation of minutes on the 10th of
October do we have any questions or
comments
seems not could I please move that these
are true and
correct uh counselor Phillip seconded by
uh councelor mcf I will put the motion
all those in favor please say I I and
against the motion is
carried
uh confirmation of minutes of the
ordinary meeting on the 31st of October
any questions or comments in here uh
councelor Reed thank you Mr Mayor um
just one um point of clarification I
asked the general manager on page 15
about the unbudgeted items on the for
democracy costs and there is a a whole
list there but one that was missing that
she said was uh an increase in travel
and accommodation for the meor and
that's actually not included in the
minutes I wonder if that could be added
please for
clarity got that Susan
happy any further questions or
comments could I please hear a move that
those are true and correct and for the
addition that councelor readed uh Mo and
seconded by councelor Paul
mcf I will put the motion all those in
favor please
say and against motion is
carried confirmation of the emergency
meeting held on Wednesday the 8th of
November any questions or comments on
these
minutes uh councelor Richard
mcf yes just through worship and uh with
due respect page
22 uh there was two lots of points of
order
called I think they're subject to uh the
standing orders
I'm just wish to clarify and confirm can
the
chair act on a point of order in regard
to section 26 just for for clarification
really and future
reference my understanding of standing
orders uh is that usually if it's about
the per performance of the chair you
would pass it on uh to in this case the
deputy Mia however the reason I didn't
in that case is because it wasn't
a point of order in my opinion so if you
go to standing orders it has to be very
clear as to what the point of order was
it was the point of order was made under
uh whether it was relevant under
262c I think it was the relevance and
I'm just clarifying whether you can um
whether it's appropriate for you to have
made that point of order on both myself
and um uh councelor
hovell Just for future reference if if
we're that's fine yeah
C cond sorry standing
orders if if Mr respect you wish just uh
262c is just uh that it was irrelevant
to inform the chair that the topic being
discussed is not the matter currently
before the meeting which was uh the
relevance to it and uh you basically
said I don't believe that's correct and
then moved
on yes counselor uh I get the point
you're
making yeah yeah I I know the one but
there is a uh so 26.3 if you read on uh
expressing a difference of opinion or
contradicting a statement by the
previous speaker does not constitute a a
point of order so that's that's what I
was basing my decision on is that if you
read through the minutes you didn't
specifically say that it was to do with
relevant
so that's why I made that decision but
but point taken in the future I can just
defer it straight away if that makes
ccil is more comfortable thank you
worship any further questions on those
minutes no could I please have a move
that those are true and
correct councelor Richard mcf seing by
councelor Dixon all those in favor
please say I and and against the motion
is
carried uh confirmation of the minutes
of the meeting the audit and risk
committee did we have any questions or
comments appear to be none uh could have
move these are true and correct and uh
to move any other recommendations in
there uh Council Stringer seing by
councelor Mell all those in favor please
say I and against the motion is carried
and lucky last uh the confirmation of
the minutes of the policy and Regulatory
committee uh held on the 14th of
November counc at the bottom of page 29
the last paragraph starting some may
argue the owners of properties that had
architectural vintage the word should be
value
thank you councelor any other questions
or
comments could I please have a move that
they are true and correct um any of the
recommendations in there and the uh
amendment by councilor
hoval happy to move seconded by Council
Stringer I will put the motion all those
in favor please say I and against the
motion is carried thank you councelor
was um seem to have quite a few meetings
which is um
progress uh moving on to Urgent late
business um I will jump the gun here um
I have a piece of urgent late business
uh relating to the lgz young elected
members H attendance um this was a
report asked for by the U deputy mayor
uh the reason it is urgent is because um
it was asked for after the publication
of this agenda uh and the h will take
place before uh the next meeting I'm
happy to move that as urgently at
business do I have a second I'm happy to
see him there thank you
council do we have any questions about
the Urgent late
business I'll put the motion all those
in favor please sayi and against the
motion is carried I will just um give a
second um to hand out the report we will
deal with it as the last item of
business um which will give councils
plenty of time to read through it in the
meantime so it'll become the new item 16
before we go
in
did we have any other urgent late
business does not seem like
it uh we had a move a second TR to all
those in favor no I'll put the motion
all those in favor please say I and
against motion is Carri that is now item
16 moving on to item
five get
my timer
up uh we have the petition for the
appointment of the interim chief
executive uh I'd like to welcome Hayden
McIntyre up to the stand um before you
do your
worship I move that the presenter is not
permitted to speak to the petition as
this is an employment matter this motion
is authorized by standing order
17.2 as set out on the agenda
worship I'd like to second
that uh Havey for a mve in a second can
we just take a moment to make sure what
the procedure is here um because it is
in our standing orders that is the right
um to be able to speak to a petition um
so are you looking to is sorry was the
standing or that you reference an
exception to that wrong 17.2 says the
petitioner may speak unless the meeting
resolve
otherwise ah
okay
Y in that case if there's are standing
orders you're welcome to uh move and
second
that the floor is open for
debate
given it appears no one wishes to speak
I would uh suggest that the motion be
put okay
um this says caught me off guard um as
my understanding was all petitioners
were allowed to speak but it does stay
understanding orders that um you are to
resolve otherwise so unless there is any
further
comment uh councelor
McKenzie I just ask one question why in
this particular
case when other people can speak to
petitions there needs to be a
reason and that reason is thank you
thank you Council McKenzie Council Dixon
this is an employment matter between the
council and the
CEO I totally get that um whether the
petition has any effect or not um I
understand that it is an employment
issue but
um we probably all know what the result
will
be but I do believe that people have the
right to
speak and I totally agree that it is an
employment issue yes I concur with
that thank you counselor thank you
counselor is there any further
discussion on this
topic um I I agree with counil McKenzie
that um while I may or may not agree
with the petition um I still do feel
like it uh should be the right of
petitioners to speak
um we have some pretty strict guidelines
and standing orders of um what people
are allowed and and not allowed to say
but U as I said before there is a
provision in standing orders as as
Council Dixon rightly pointed out
um so yeah but is what it is that's our
standing orders um if there's no further
discussion I will put the motion all
those in favor please say
I and against
the motion is carried um Hayden you can
sit back
down uh so we will move on to uh
debating
the we'll move on to debating the issue
uh councelor Phillips thank youa um I'd
like to move that the mayor and the
councilors do not receive this petition
the appointment of the chief
interim
executive
I second the
motion thank you councilors the uh
motion on the tables to not proceed the
report um is open for
debate you wish there petition
thanks sorry what was that the petition
should not be received yes yeah got that
um it's open for debate do we have any
questions or comments from
councilors
Council have hour yes thank you your
worship I just have a slight malfunction
in the
software that's
here given that I'm going to be quoting
from documents I think it's important
that um the the um matter come up before
me just one moment
please does councilor FS want to go
thank you no got it
start this petition in my view is
divisive and an unnecessary an unwelcome
distraction from the purpose for which I
stood for the council the petition has
been instigated by the McIntyre family
members and is not the only
correspondence that I have received from
them throughout this year Sally McIntyre
bombards me and other counselors on a
regular basis with inappropriate emails
and I'd like to read to you the email
that I received last week dear
counselors poel Dixon and mfil one
wonders when you will wake up to the
pathetic actions your pathetic actions
why do you keep on digging yourself El
in a hole for the sake of our district
your resignations will be much
appreciated as it's very clear you're
not up to the job Fed Up rate payer s
McIntyre if I continue to receive such
emails from s McIntyre I will be asking
the it manager at the council to put a
ban on her emails coming into this
Council there is of course a precedence
for such action as sell McIntyre will
recall in 2010 when the council would
not accept emails from her that was the
culmination of a series of events dating
back to 2007 when she resigned from the
council Tracy Hicks me at the time is
reportedly told Mrs McIntyre the health
and well-being of council staff must be
accorded higher priority than engaging
in your personal Crusade it seems little
has changed over the last 13 years
except it's now the health and
well-being of some counselors and staff
that's at risk I'd rather be devoting my
time as Cher to waset working on a
community scheme for full recycling
across the whole region and for Gore I'd
rather be have my role as chair of the
council's policy and Regulatory
committee focusing on attracting
development and future growth in this
area so that the young people that we
have uh our children don't have to leave
home to find jobs or to find further
education I'd much rather be discussing
with my fellow counselors the
introduction of a new rating scheme that
is fair and reasonable and puts us in
place for moving forward time taken up
by these petitions and these emails is
stopping me from undertaking what I
believe are the important tasks in this
community my V motivation in making
decisions around this table is
determined by what I believe is best for
the community and at times that requires
me to put aside my personal views a case
in point the pipeline under of the uh to
get the water across the Mata River my
personal view was strongly we should
have a bridge my community view taking
everything into account was put it under
the river at times too decisions that I
make around this table involve a cost to
the council a case in point the um
ceasing of payment for getting books out
of the library that idea came from me it
was promoted by me and I moved the the
motion for it and it was passed with and
unanimous support it had a cost but it
was the right thing to do I do wonder
the motiv motivations of the petition
organizers I want to highlight why I
supported the appointment of the interim
chief executive reason one it provide
stability having continuity in
leadership to the staff and continuity
in the advice received by counselors
reason two it enables a seamless
transition to the appointment of a new
chief executive re reason three it
provides confidence to the community
that the business of council continues
uninterrupted reason four the major
review we're currently undertaking of
the long-term plan enables us to
consider a new rating system that's fear
and um appropriate using the
considerable knowledge and expertise of
the man who has overseen it for the last
20 years reason five the council has a
legal and moral responsibility to ensure
it continues to operate effectively and
efficiently if any elected member
believes I'm wrong with regard to any of
these please speak up to my fellow
counselors I invite you to think why you
stood for councel if like me you stood
seeking to enhance the social economic
cultural and physical well-being of the
people and community and this great area
we call Gore then you must support the
motion to Sally McIntyre I say I will
not be resigning from Council I will
continue working towards outcomes that I
believe are in the best interest of the
district a case in point the appointment
of the interim chief executive thank
you thank you councelor councilor
fell I just like to ask if there any
other councilors before I the for order
say I'd like to concur with councelor
Havel's very heartfelt statement I think
um we are here to do a job we've been
elected to do that and this some of
these proceedings have been um malicious
in intent and taking causing stress to
staff and elected members
alike
obviously councelor haval has put it his
case very well and I cannot add to that
but thank him for
it thank you
counselor
Council
Phillips thank you your
worship Council was um added most of the
the bullet points about why we chose
what we did in employing the
ex um chief executive Stephen Perry as
an interim chief chief executive and our
decision that we made I believe was the
best interest of the
district and his points were were about
the workload that was currently
happening at the moment uh especially
just a one month out from Christmas
period I can assure the the
residents of this District that I put
everything 110% into
Council I make these decisions not
lightly and I make sure that what I'm
saying and doing is in the best interest
not only of of uh EV rer but of the
whole you know of the whole District
then and I believe what we
did was the correct thing to do until
such time as we got to the point about
employing a new chief
executive thank
you thank you councelor any further
comments councilor dexon and then
councelor mcel I just have one comment
to make about the petition actually
because stated in the petition that says
the unwillingness to work with elected
elected members that's the CEO's
unwillingness that is not a correct
statement that is a false
statement thank you councelor Council
mcf it's just R your worship a couple of
comments I think it's been covered quite
uh quite thoroughly by the other
counselors I think uh what we're seeing
here today is some stability um only
today we see in the media that the
Christ Church CEO is not returning to
his position commentary
there oh her her position thank you
worship I'll let you correct me there
um her but we see that and
um the bottom line is that we need some
stability amongst our senior management
team we've got a good team there and it
was a decision that had to be made and
it gives us that continuity and it's sad
that we have to sit here today and'll be
members of the community thinking that
we're digging holes and thinking we
should resign and the various emails
that we receive so be it we are members
of this community we don't deserve some
of the abuse we get but that's a fact of
life when we line up and climb the
ladder more of us is
bad so I think we need to get on with it
um there's been some great commentary
there from councelor hoval the biggest
thing that we need to reassure the
community is we need to meet our
statutory requirements if we haven't got
a senior management team that can
actually work
I don't think you'd be worrying about
myself or um M Bell because if we don't
meet our requirements our Council can be
taken over by other people other
government
agencies so we do need that stability so
it's about all of us not just the
collective group that sits here and
people every week think that we're
making decisions and votes around uh
personalities or conflicts we're
actually trying to do the best for the
community and I think you need to think
about that instead of continually
looking in the rear Vision mirror at
that what's happened in the
past thank you
worship thank you
councelor councelor
mcell I I concur with councelor mcf's
comments stability is what we need we
need to find a good new CEO and if we
end up scrapping and fighting over
things we're just going to end up get
getting uh not the right applicants to
come here so we we we need to get over
this and move forward and get on with
the job of finding a new
CEO thank you
counselor anybody
else all happy oh councelor Paul
mcf thank you your worship um look I
just add my my um support to that I've
just written down here and I may not be
right but I've never witnessed a more
vindictive revengeful unrel in bitter
campaign in my life saddens me to be
part of this community we are trying to
do the best we can so I do support what
council have and everyone else has
said Thank You
counselors
um going to refrain from from talking
about Steve in particular um for
employment matter sake um and for
clarity I will be abstaining from the
vote for for that exact reason
what I will say um to reassure the
public is if you do have concerns uh we
are recruiting for a new chief executive
it is out there at the moment that is a
process that that continues there is
stability in the organization at the
moment from from what I can see um
myself and the chief executive have have
a good arrangement in place we're used
to that uh we're working through that um
and and I and I'll leave it at that at
this stage um I'll just yeah keep keep
it keep it neutral um as Stuart rightly
said um there's an employment process
and and the MS the moment and we need to
do Best by
that if there's no further comments I
will put the motion which as it stands
is to reject the petition
correct I'll put the motion all those in
favor please say
I and
against I will be abstaining it's okay
thank you
councilors
something a bit more cheery presentation
from Charmy uh presentation from Great
South if you wanted to come to the front
um you will you need the
projector and welcome to gore good to
have you
back one speak
no
thank I know your voice
is thank
you we have
a thank
you I
know so I might have to take
that
we'll just we'll just have a quick two
minute break in between just so that
people can yeah just have a
[Music]
second
are you
ready
e
when you're oh even got it up when
you're ready Charming take it away I'm
just waiting for the presentation to Lo
sorry oh yeah so thank
you
B
now
what
Koto coam TOA good afternoon everybody
and thank you for having me and my
esteemed colleague Bobby Brown um to
speak to you I'm extremely privileged
and honored to be here today I've been
um hoping to get in front of the council
for a while um I've been in the job as
the chief executive of Great South for
about a year and um it's been one of my
uh um key sort of deliverables that I
wanted to have more engagement with uh
our councils uh especially those funding
counselors um so that you are aware of
what we do and how we support you and
your uh District so um what we would
want want to do today is very quickly
run through some of the stuff that has
happened a little bit about Great South
um I'm not sure how many of you are um
aware of EX exactly what we do um and uh
um we've done a significant piece of
work over the last uh 18 months which is
called Beyond 2025 and I uh did meet
some of the councilors and of course uh
his worship the mayor was with us at the
launch of that particular long-term plan
but it's a long-term plan for our region
and so we were hoping to have um Bobby
will take us through uh a bit of that
information and how it has and will
impact Gore District Council uh will be
highlighted here and I'd like to end
really just the about the long ter um
the letter of expectation and the uh
statement of intent process that we're
going through at the moment um of course
uh identifying some of our challenges
and um putting that forward for the
council to consider at the next council
meeting I believe um we will have a
paper up to the council for
consideration then so this is just for
your information please uh feel free to
shout out uh with any uh questions you
may have um I'm more than happy to take
it at that time or we can take it at the
end um I'll um I'm easy so you let me
know what you would like me to do right
so really uh Great South is uh a council
controlled organization with nine
shareholders out of which we have uh
what we call the class A shareholders or
our funding shareholders uh which is uh
inago city council Southland District
Council Gore District Council and the
Regional Council um environment souland
we also have five other shareholders ERS
um sit ilt U matara licensing trust um
the Chamber of commers and we also have
a member organization uh Community Trust
of South uh Community Trust souland
sorry and um they provide us with some
funding for investigation and impetus um
activities so our vision has been to um
build even better lives through
sustainable Regional development and
um we as an organization are now
currently five years old four years old
sorry um we morphed from what was
Venture souland into Great South in
2019 and when we moved into uh Great
South we became a council controlled
organization uh at that point we there
was a new board that was appointed a
commercially astute uh board that was
tasked with uh
directing Great South um to make the
best business decisions uh so that we
could see the best return on investment
for our region um recently what we have
done is we held a few um workshops with
our joint shareholders and these are the
new priorities that have come out of uh
the latest uh Workshop was in September
the one before that was in May this year
so we've had two this year and really
looking at Regional development
leadership and when we're talking about
that we're talking about the Beyond 2025
long-term plan that will set a
foundation for how we as a Southland
region as a whole can move up and move
forward and develop we uh look at
Regional promotion we also provide
business support and diversification and
we also work with our businesses to take
them along the net zero or the
decarbonization journey as we as a
country have signed up to the Paris
agreement as you'll know so we've got a
um commitment to become Net Zero by
2050 um we Great South has been dabbling
in this area for a number of years and
we've already issued several strategies
on how we can get there we have a net
zero Southland strategy and um part of
the work that we do here is to
incorporate that strategy and bring it
to life um this is us so um I'm up there
Bobby leads our Beyond 2025 uh Team uh
well project she's no longer has a team
sorry it's only her um times are tough
resources are hard to come by so we've
got to make some sacrifices uh Steve
Kenny he's um and I'm sure he's um known
to many of you um GM of strategic
projects Mark was taken on to Phil
Bobby's old position of Tourism and
events and we have a new um GM of uh
Finance it and Facilities Suzanne
Suzanne comes to us from PowerNet and
before that she was with envir Southland
so has some experience in local
government I come I came to um Great
South from sit so I've lived in New
Zealand for 13 years out of that 12
years I was at sit I first came as an
international student and then stayed on
and I was um employed by them and uh
when I left sit I was on the senior
management team leading international
education marketing pastoral care
various other things it's a really long
story you don't want to hear that anyway
so in a nutshell this is kind of like
where we are we delve into those four
areas four or five areas that we spoke
about um Regional development um
business support that uh generally falls
under strategic projects um Mark handles
everything tourism and events and as I
mentioned before Bobby is beyond 2025
but everything that Bobby does underpins
uh the other areas as
well in uh 2022 and 2023 and I'm
conscious that I'm putting this up it's
about a year old but this is um because
I haven't had a chance to be in front of
the council before but Gore uh uh
District Council gave us uh 200 200 a
over
$200,000 uh the total funding in that
particular year was quite High we had uh
7.6 million out of which you can see we
had other sources so uh during Co
because you had a regional development
agency uh this region was able to get
over seven um um over $7 million in
Government funding over the um Co period
so helped support the businesses to stay
afloat helped support uh tourism helped
support uh with very very many different
strategies and um uh working plans that
we have now established um in 2023 your
funding went up to
222,000 uh however our total funding has
uh did come down to um be a little over
6 million and again um we had government
funding that came through um however
most of those contracts are now at an
end or closing at the end of this year
now for um as I mentioned before um the
uh government assisted many regions uh
Great South owns and operates two
Regional um tourism organizations visit
fand and visit Southland and because of
that we were actually able to get a
little bit more money than some of the
other RTO and the other regions um which
is a bit of a sore point but hell money
came to us and that's what we wanted so
uh this is where the money came from the
step uh funding we had Regional events
um funding and that will go on until
June
2024 um and then we had uh tourism
communities um and some recovery support
that came through so again if we didn't
have a central organization that was
control controlled by the councils but
acted independently you would we
wouldn't have got this money into our
region so it's important to understand
why um uh we as an organization exist
for you um Regional leadership so this
leads us on to our Beyond 2025 plan and
I'll hand it over to Bobby Brown to take
over no one likes seeing a photo of
themselves that's for sure um but like
hi guys um nice to be back again
obviously I'm from Gore so um this is
home but look I'm just going to run
through seven or eight slides just to
give you an update and apologies to some
people who know bit more than others um
but this is a very important piece of
work so it was launched in
July or end of June um this year so it's
called Beyond 2025 south regional
long-term plan uh so look at it came
from a background of um Ty saying they
were going to close and the government
saying right we've got to support South
to look at you know what's after Ty you
know how can we help um look at
different diversification opportunities
so it brought a whole lot of people
together and the result were was seven
work streams one of which was saying
right let's put a long-term lens over
everything else Great South then put
their hand up and said we'll help
facilitate that and this piece of work
happened at the same time we had
completed almost 2third of all the
things that were in our previous
Regional development strategy which if
you recall was called swords and so it
was we thought right let's be clever and
put these two things together so that we
just have Clarity with one strategic
Regional document and that's what
happened um so the reason why our faces
are up there is because we're very very
lucky to have recently won um a national
award with economic development New
Zealand for best integrated strategy so
we're quite proud of that because
sometimes you know you're doing a good
job you've talked to a lot of people but
it's always good good to get that
acknowledged by your
peers so look just really quickly there
was a lot of work that went into
developing this plan and I often say the
process to develop it was probably more
important than what it says so there
were 16 work streams there were four
advisory groups they went from
environment and climate change through
to community economic marketing local
business support and of course
population that basically shows that a
lot of stuff happened so nine Public
Road shows over 20 huie with maninoa um
over 50 reports and pieces of research
were reviewed as part of this and 20
pieces of separate primary research were
undertaken from a regional energy
assessment a housing needs assessment
which I'll show you in a second through
to talking to local businesses um we did
some work on volunteers so we really
tried to be clever and cover lots of
different parts and I don't know if
clever was the word but that's just
that's just showing that we didn't sort
of pull the stuff out of fresh year um
it's based on fact and insight as much
as we
can I'd like to acknowledge Gore
District Council staff and some of the
counselors because we would not have got
this quality piece of work if a lot of
staff had not very generously given us
their time um in particular an Paula um
Steve cheering the housing Advisory
Group um your expertise was just
absolutely invaluable and I think that's
as a result of where we are now with the
housing situation um but an negotiated a
lot of stuff for us with other Council
staff like Jason Rick Sonia um lots of
people so thank you so much for that um
we know you had a lot on um but again
wouldn't have got to this stage without
you so what that slide to shows is
different staff touching different parts
of the
plan in terms of the the plan I won't go
into too much but look it's pretty basic
it's about three aspirations based on
our people our economy and our
environment so things like we're going
to look after the place we live in
because it's how we Prosper things like
making sure that our people are happy
and healthy and that we have fairness
and equity and social well-being and
things like the economy that we remain a
Powerhouse for the country but we also
make sure we've got jobs for people and
that we're divers ified our economy so
if we've got a lot of eggs in one basket
we're not hurt when that basket might
change so that's basically just a
summary of how it all turned
out we identified five key enablers
because sometimes with these strategies
you end up with a lot of things in it we
wanted to make sure that the big five
were focused on and got priority so no
surprises here or I hope no surprises
but you've got housing we'll talk about
that in a second we've got Workforce
particularly with an unemployment rate
which fluctuates below 3% which is a
structural Baseline you've got data
energy and Regulatory and planning which
does acknowledge that there's a lot
coming at councils and across the whole
Community um and that is having an
impact but it also acknowledges that if
we want things to happen regionally the
rules have to enable or understand what
they
are so for you guys um look there's a
lot of alignment between the Regional
plan and what your aspirations are and
again we've got that because your staff
are involved but things like look a
region is built on the connection
between our Urban and our rural
communities really important but that
obviously means a lot of stuff has to
enable that to happen talking about
embracing change because we're connected
and resilient and we talked about things
like Gore kids Hub you know facilities
which allow people to be together the
multisports complex you know you guys
have done really well here with the
breadth and and quality of your
facilities and again what I talked about
before with being exposed to large
employers or industry changing so there
were a couple of sections in the plan
and I forgot to bring some today gosh
tragedy um but I can definitely get some
copies to you in they online but around
Community Workforce tourism and that
focus on Rural communities so lots of
stuff that you're doing fits into the
regional picture and the regional
picture validates and endorses your work
so one of the big things we did was
trying to understand now who our people
are and trying to get an understanding
of who our people will be in the future
so that's really important and your
Council staff do this already but what
we that's important when you're thinking
of infrastructure you got to provide
housing Etc so what we tried to do was
to link the councils up you know so that
we had a common understanding across the
whole region so we did five Baseline
reports for you guys with infometrics
support and then we we had that crystal
ball out thinking about what the future
might look like so this is not a
surprise um backs up all the stuff that
that Ann and the team have probably been
talking to about um but you have a very
very old and aging population and that
will continue um in line with the rest
of the country and the world in
fact okay another biggie was housing so
we did a full audit of every house in
the region and there's about 46,000
homes uh Gore has about 5 and a half
thousand and that number can fluctuate
because depends of trusts own them and
that sort of thing so what we do we can
tell you a lot about what type of houses
you have where they are who lives in
them so why is this important um for
lots of reasons um but it's also
important because tourism events are
quite big for you guys and 2% of your
housing stock is ebnb for example so not
quite as good as Tiana which has 16% um
I don't know if Goods the word there
because it does present a challenge when
you're trying to house
staff okay so what we did was we looked
at your housing Supply so we looked at
lots of different ways that your housing
could be grouped we looked at
affordability so understanding um how
people can afford properties what how
you guys comp to the rest of the region
because that of course fits into when
you're trying to attract
Workforce and we looked at future
projections which um looks at build rate
efficiencies Etc so this is an
electronic tool which we developed
through the housing group and it's out
of date the moment you develop it so
we're going to look at trying to get a
consistent way to have this information
available to council and developers and
others last slide I feel maybe second
last um we've also done something called
a commercial accommodation audit which
basically means we count the number of
rooms and Commercial properties for you
guys and we have a good chap to your
operators so this is really important
because you know you want to bring
events tourism into the region you can
clip the ticket if they can stay if they
can't they'll just keep going through
and stay somewhere else so look over Co
um you've recovered quite well so your
number of rooms has stayed pretty
consistent and um just a few home stays
have actually um stopped operating as
home stays is probably the biggest um
Trend here last slide so in terms of the
plan being launched uh we've got four
priorities that we're working on in the
next six months so housing is obviously
very big because we want to look at
regionally you know what how do we
measure success you know how do we deal
with this very complex issue so there's
a whole lot in there around action plans
Supply programs helping making it easy
for developers um but even just sharing
the information
there's also a lot of a focus on
homeowners so we've got some of the
oldest housing stock in the country so
73% of all of our homes were built prior
to
1980 so we'll have to replace about
10,000 Homes at some point up to 2050 so
what we want to do is help homeowners
know where they can get different energy
you know and retrofit pink bats there
actually a lot of good work already
happening with the South and warm homes
trust
Etc uh the other project is a data
dashboard and repository so lots of
information we're just trying to make a
One-Stop shop so it's easy for people to
find it and to inform
decisions there's some work on water so
we're working with the Regional Council
environment Southland um just trying to
understand and support their Mahi and
the energy strategy and what happens
with energy linked to decarbonization is
obviously um quite key um particularly
with the national energy strategy
underway and of of course we generate in
the South they need it in the north it's
got to get there um but we're obviously
quite Keen to to understand what we need
as a region to reach Net Zero by
2050 and there's definitely a plan as
charm said around Net Zero Southland
with that but it's really pleasing that
we've already abated
14.8% um which is fantastic so a lot of
the private sector have have really
stood up and embracing that
change
finished thank you um so just going
quickly um I know we don't have a lot of
time so I'm going to touch on this uh
won't speak too much about it but there
will be uh facts and figures
specifically um associated with Gore um
marketing uh means that we will promote
campaigns across uh the country
sometimes overseas uh to encourage
visitors to come through to um our part
of the world we also uh host the fils um
and um I think the most recent um famous
person to come down was the Hoff um we
will be rolling out a thing called the
ambassador program where we intend to
have front-facing firstline staff um
encourage anybody that they engage with
and speak to them about what is good
about your region so they will have
specifics about Gore to speak to
visitors that come into Gore um
destination development is um really
around our um product products for
tourism and um how we can make our
tourism more sustainable um and of a
value to us as well as to the visitor we
very recently launched last week
actually um uh the destination U Miko
Southland destination strategy in Gore
unfortunately the first time around when
we wanted to come there were flood so we
weren't able to um and there's a whole
range of uh products and um activities
that we have within that strategy that
we intend to implement for cor events is
another key area as you know you've got
quite a few um unmissable events over
the calendar and this will encourage
tourism tourism encourages Workforce to
come here Workforce will then you know
support our Economic Development um
initiatives we have um launch the events
strategy and we also have a calendar of
events especially the admiss events so
what we're trying to do um one of the
other programs that we have is partnered
with um seven other art OS uh in the
lowest part of the South Ireland and
established what is called the southern
way and we want people to stop and slow
down and actually take time to go
through our region and um uh the there
will be certain itineries that will be
available alongside these events so that
people will stay long in your region and
support your um economic development
business events is um a key area that we
understand that we can um promote
visitors to our region in the offseason
so it doesn't give too much stress on
our um you know Peak Seasons during
summer and uh it also encourages people
to stay here for about 3 four five days
pre and post events to come out into
this part of the world as
well um business support and
diversification is really two key areas
that we have in this uh that we have
activated over the last few years is the
regional business um uh Regional uh
Business Partnership program which is a
contract with MB and through that we
support businesses with capability
building um and this these are some of
the figures for 2023 and 2024 to date uh
specifically for Gore but overall uh
over a year we will meet with about 100
50 businesses to determine their um uh
capabilities and to provide them with
one-on-one assistance but we will have
more than about 250 to 280 business
engagements so it's quite a significant
piece of work that we do there uh I'm
not sure if you guys have heard about
the Southland youth Futures program
Southland youth Futures goes into our
schools across um our Miku region and we
work with students to identify career
opportunities there are two different um
aspects of this we deliver a thing
called the uh work ready passport and we
also provide events um the events uh
allow our students to understand what it
really means to be in a particular
industry to become an aror arborous for
example or to become a vet or to you
know um be a waiter so ilt and they have
various different games or over various
different methodologies that um students
engage with to understand whether they
can actually carry a plate without a a
tray of stuff without dropping it so a
very engaging um way tool and um we've
engaged with over 2,600 students across
the region this um last year and that's
the work ready uh passport program so
we're working with um your the high
schools
here um and of course offered um
professional talks to the schools as
well NetZero Southland I touched very
quickly on this we've got a number of
programs that we um provide to
businesses to support them to embark on
a a decarbonization journey so we've
only had one Gore business uh so far uh
to get onto that program so there will
be greater concentration to bring other
businesses along on this
journey ah and we we had a second win in
about four weeks um last Friday the
sustainability uh program won an award
from business South in denen um so
recognizing businesses across Southland
and atago um and um it was for um the
decarbonization program because we've
already had 74 businesses engaged but as
Bobby mentioned before overall our
region has uh reduced our carbon
emissions by 14.8 % from our Baseline in
2018 so it's a significant event um
significant effort by many
people um what's next looking ahead
right so this is uh really um as as I
mentioned before resources are tight um
our costs are quite High one thing I
didn't mention in my presentation is
that uh Great South owns uh space
operations space operations engages in
um satellite observation data exchange
um so if you use your phone and you get
onto your GPS those signals
predominantly would have come through
the satellites that we download data
from in Bluff so um space operations
actually pulled out as as an independent
um company in
2021 and they've been in operation now
for a a little over a year so it was
October 21 when they moved into that
stance so prior to that uh space
operation
um actually uh enabled us to cover any
shortfalls that we faced um from funding
um now that that's gone now that um the
government funding has gone and covid
funding has gone we find that we do have
a bit of a shortfall um this year in
2023 24 year we will be um covering that
difference of $200,000 or $210,000 with
our uh cash reserves but that brings our
cash Reserves right down to the area
that we need to be um in order to keep
us afloat so um if you look at the
breakdown of course and I and this is uh
Gore district has very kindly committed
to $660,000 for contract funding this
year and for next year and for next year
we're looking at uh our core overheads
being 1.9 million and
um um putting a request forward uh
through
to see if you would have an opportunity
to look at um roughly contributing about
10% uh based on great Sal's shareholder
agreement the core funding is divided by
the four funding councils 50% from uh
inago city council uh 30% from SDC 10%
from Gore and 10% from uh environment
Southland but that is being under review
at the moment so uh the outcome of it
I'm not really sure sure what will
happen but um whatever it is it will be
implemented in 2025 26 and so if we were
to request Gore to consider a slight
increase to their core contribution that
would be around an additional
$35,000 for um from you to us that will
enable us to keep us in the or it'll
just be we're breaking even if we do
that do that so that's me and I'm happy
to take questions Bobby's happy to take
questions thank you very much uh both
Charmy and Bobby um sly not as exciting
for me as I've heard most of the
information um but I'm sure councilors
would have indulged in that uh
councilors do we have any questions um
we have uh prematurely arranged a bit of
a workshop possibly in the future with
Charmy and want to jump in the gun a
little bit absolutely we definitely can
organize a workshop with Charmy um if
there are quite a few questions from uh
counselors here today I know that we
have quite a big agenda um but I will
allow questions to flow
now yeah councelor Fraser yeah I'll just
make a point because I was tasked with
getting out to counselors to see if they
had any questions but I had a glitch in
The Matrix and I only got my computer
working properly yesterday but with this
other meeting coming up I think it might
be more appropriate if those questions
that I had
and and I'll give you an update it's
around the O plant um made then um
because you use the words Regional
development leadership and to me no
leadership was shown there
so I'll jump in there for for Charmy um
we can possibly get Ian along as well um
but but that'll probably be a bit of
conversation to have in a in a in a
workshop it'll means that the team can
get into yes and unfortunately it's not
something that I am responsible for so I
will bring Ian around and I think it is
a good opportunity for us to discuss
that um at that
Workshop thank you councelor faser
councelor
Stringer uh thanks guys for your
presentation there just um Bobby the
figures that you're showing on the
screen there um do we have access to
that as cels like you'll send us a link
through that we get to
yeah y cool thank
you any further questions for the team I
imagine everyone's probably holding back
for a later date that counsel got on I I
just noticed the space Ops was a very
profitable um operation and um going
ahead quite well now U you've passed it
on why wasn't the um profits kept back
in the business to cover these
Rises um we decided Well I didn't decide
the board decided to go down that Avenue
so that there's opportunity for greater
growth as a part of great out they
wouldn't have had the ability to grow to
the extent and as quickly as they wanted
to so currently with space up standing
alone they've also taken over walk worth
in uh Oakland which has opened up a
whole new dimension of space observation
so we're now able to go into deep space
and we're also able to go into Earth
observation which will enable us like um
in case of um drastic weather events on
how the um the effect of any floods or
tsunamis or you know it could be a uh
earthquake or whatever it is so uh we
are able to now invest and uh put that
money back into that company there will
be some uh Capital that is required for
space HS um which but it will enable an
exponential growth and a much much
larger return on investment which will
help us to then um reduce the Reliance
on the rate payers money so the AL
ultimate goal is that whatever we can do
to reduce the Reliance on rap pairs
money is where we're going to be trying
to head
to thank you chth you Council just jump
in there as well I think again I's
probably a pretty good person to talk to
why the why the board made that decision
um and just for clarification great sou
to owns 100% of space obsid separate
Institute that's right yes we do thank
you Council Reed thank you Mr Mayor
Bobby a question for you thank you both
you and chy for coming up and speaking
um but it's just something maybe to keep
in mind for the future going forward
many of people in our community um and
most of the rate rate payers that I
speak to around this issue is homing we
housing we have a lot of renters that
are aging quite rapidly many of them are
actually female and many of them
actually only have the pension to rely
on and even if accommodation is
available it's actually quite often out
of their reach they live hand to mouth
so going forward I would like great
South to perhaps um give look at options
around that for the gore District
specifically for us thank you good and
is already working with those groups as
well so in Partnership we
def thank you councilors one last
question for the team we'll try to get
this moving along
thank you very much um we'll likely see
you again very shortly for the thank you
very much than for having us thank
you moving right along to the minutes of
the Great South joint shareholders
committee meeting we have any questions
with those
minutes
can I have a move the minutes be
received uh councelor Philip seconded by
counselor
mcdonell any further
comments I will put the motion all those
in favor please say I and against the
motion is
carried number eight chief executive
recruitment subcommittee on page
85 would the deputy may like to speak to
this memo at
all thank you your worship um I think
the memo is is is self-explanatory at a
previous meeting it was agreed there' be
some terms of reference drawn up and and
they they show up on pages 86 and
87 um so in terms of the um
recommendations that are there that the
report be received um but I wish to
amend the the second one and the reason
for that is that at the bottom of page
87 or um bottom of 86 and 87 it sets out
limitations of the subcommittee and I'd
like to add another
limitation and it be a separate one
without the little dash of the bullet
points and and that is that the chair of
the subcommittee does not have a casting
vote so the intent is that we'll be four
on the committee and the key task of the
committee is to reduce the number of
applicants to a long list and then to a
short list for a recommendation to
council um by not having the intent is
it be done by consensus um but if a full
um majority isn't reached um if two out
of the four feel an name should go
forward then that's what um will happen
so um the mayor the chair of the
subcommittee and myself had had um
talkies and reached the view that that
was an appropriate thing in this case um
so I I I would move that the the report
be um received and subject to the
addition of the chair of the
subcommittee doesn't have a casting vote
that the terms of reference has set out
on pages 86 87 um be adopted and happy
to answer any
questions thank you councelor look for a
second before get into debate uh
councelor Dixon uh open for debate
questions
Etc so we're all happy on getting nod
all around just a clarification for the
public um that this is as Council have
said just the long list and the short
list um every single counselor will be
interviewing uh the final whatever
number is at the end so the short list
whether it's four five six who knows um
so they every single Council will have
involvement and at the end of that
process to select the chief executive
just to make that very
clear nice and
easy any
questions no I will put the motion all
those in favor please say I and against
the motion is carried thank you
councilors uh propose legis amendment to
cancel defer the 2020 longterm plan on
page 88 uh would the chief executive
like to speak to this report at
all
yeah thanks your worship um as you know
you asked me to uh prepare this report
it's fair to say that the Spector of the
um preparing a long-term plan in the
current environment with three Waters
reform
now uh very very uncertain because the
previous government had got to a stage
where it had passed legislation was
going to create 10 new entities uh to
deliver and govern uh water in New
Zealand and and Wastewater and of course
uh the the government that is hopefully
in the advanced phases of formation um
has said uh certain the major party has
said National party that they will scrap
free Waters and uh best I can discern is
that they're talking about the creation
of U Regional local
ccos um but in the meantime the the
business of the Council of council has
to continue and it struck will struck us
way back in April actually at the uh
zone five and six uh local government
meeting in Queenstown uh where I raised
this issue um and I think Council
Stringer and his worship with with there
uh amongst other councils it it got a
reasonable amount of support then but I
think a lot of councils probably didn't
actually think it was such a burning
problem then but uh fast forward 6
months and um I was at the rural and
provincial count council meeting in
early November with councilor hoval and
yes the the grip of Fear and uncertainty
amongst certainly my colleagues about
how we're going to prepare this
long-term plan with such um marked
uncertainty uh with three Waters um
earmarked for um being being scrapped in
in terms of the law about the the
council's being charged with
administering law as we know it now um
and trying to credibly put out 10 years
worth of forecasting where you think
that the rug could easily be taken from
under you with a policy change as the
government so my view has always been
well why don't you just simply scrap the
need for an ltp and Carri on with an
annual plan and um literally just for
this term of council would mean that
every Council Museum would just be
reliant on the long-term plan that was
cast uh nearly 3 years ago and I'm I
guess I'm hinting in this report that it
might not be such a bad thing because
you could experience not having to do a
long-term plan and then you might
actually reflect and think well do we
need to do it every 3 years and the key
for a long-term plan is that at the
moment we're obligated to do what I
would call a first principal review like
it's not just a light once over it's an
absolute Deep dive uh to review all
aspects of your long-term plan your
asset management plans your activity
management plans your infrastructure
strategy your Finance strategy your your
performance measures uh the assumptions
that you are operating uh within all
those things are are critically reviewed
every three years and it's now taking
about half of that period 80 months to
get through that review process so I I
know that a lot of colleagues are
fatigued uh the the process currently in
my view is horrendously constipated and
it's been
captured by by the
bureaucracy and um we it's not rewarding
um Innovation or creativity it's
actually rewarding compliance and it is
a SLO and over the years I've seen this
evolve from um Financial a auditing
where go which is uh Focus mainly on
your forecasting and your underlying
assumptions now to actually telling us
what issues we should be um parading
before the community the options under
each issue the word smithing of them uh
and it just seems to be Overkill um so
that's that's my uh 20 years of
experience in as a chief executive
speaking um whether it has um the
support of the council's a moot point um
I've um allowed myself to get outside my
bureaucratic cage and tell a little bit
like it is and hopefully with this uh
situation we find the Elson we can kick
for touch from on the ltp still have all
the supporting information that we're
already working on uh but allow us to
actually not get a um severely qualified
ltp either because we've not complied
with the late released law or the public
think it's a nonsense because we're
compliant with the law but everyone
knows that law is not going to last for
very long so it's it's putting us in a
horrendous situation so that's my
overing comment your worship and um look
forward to the council's
reaction thank you uh for that Steve um
really appreciate the the dialogue and
actually the report as well um it's not
often that I read a report and actually
enjoy myself um I did enjoy your
reference to the Rugby World Cup in
there as well
um I yeah totally agree the way I've
looked at it in simplistic terms is uh
we've got to notify um our long-term
plan next year um and then put it into
action uh in the middle of next year now
if this uh incoming government like they
have so said um change what is currently
there um we're going to notify and
develop a plan as soon as it's locked in
that's it um we can't we can't just
change little things we can't take out a
third of it or put a third of it back in
so this really needs to be sorted out at
this end of it um so whether it's a
pause or or a deferral or whatever some
some sort of action needs to happen here
um otherwise I was thinking Upon A rates
Workshop um this week and thinking if we
advertise uh our rates from 2025 without
watering them it's going to seem like a
massive discount um but the the public
has no idea um how they're actually
going to pay for their water because
it's got to be paid for somehow so um I
don't really want to advertise it's
going to be discount on rates and then
there's another bill um somewhere else
so I think there needs to be some action
um really Keen to hear what councils
have to think and what that action may
look like um if there is support for
this um and starting to to understand
the implications of of a move like this
um I'll open up to the
floor cancel
oh councelor someone councelor yeah
thank you there were three options
before us as I see it number one is to
speak out as we're doing today so you
can TI the Box and um I would hope that
the Press pick up on it and talk to
other councils and see what their views
are on that number two is to use the
contacts we have through other councils
through local government New Zealand and
through the zones and and through the um
U mural forum and and those Avenues uh
to actively promote um a a hold on on
the long-term plan at the stage an
option three is to write to the new
Minister um once he's apped really
taking the crck out of what's in the
chief executive's report and and and
posing the questions and doing so in a
very public way the main concern to me
is that we if you take the staff time
into account we're going to be spending
$400 $500,000 including the audit fees
on a process that at the end of the day
I consider to be a waste of the rate
payers money um given that we could end
up with a document that that is uh I
guess nugatory without any uh effect or
or the ability to actually Implement
what's there so fully support what's in
the Chiefs executive's um report and um
I guess I I would um suggest um that the
recommendation that's in the report that
we consider our role um needs to can be
expressed in very simple terms and and
that is that the council Advocates the
delay on long-term plans through
whatever means is available to it thank
you just before thank you counselor just
before I reflect to the next speak here
um so those Avenues uh meral Forum which
I think is next Friday if I remember
correctly um there's a Zone meeting
tomorrow specifically discussing three
Waters um so if it is endorsed today um
both me and Steve can talk about it with
um the other Mayors at that uh meeting
and a letter to the minister can be
written at any time um and support can
be gathered from uh our neighboring Ms
at any time as well um those are just
the different options um just wanted to
pick up on your point the accounts of um
won't be a waste of the 400
$500,000 um only a third of that has a
big question mark over it there is twoth
thirds that will be good but I'm I'm
sure that's exactly what you meant yeah
it's not an efficient spend of our rate
payers
money agreed uh anybody else uh
councelor
Phillips yeah thank you worship um at at
their last term of council and I was the
one that voted against this coming
forward in any form whatsoever and and I
what I said then was it was going to
cost the poor rate payers money and um
the less money that we can spend on
situations that we don't have to without
government giving us some clear
indications of where they want to go
then I think uh this is a a fine start
and thank you to chief executive for the
report thank you councelor C
thank you Mr Mayor um thanks Steve it's
a good report and it's a smart idea um I
just hope you get credit for it
nationally actually um the thing is
change is Swift and costs are escalating
and we're a very small Council and we
know how bogged down we can get with
those costs so I would actually like to
um just hope that the recommendation is
accepted by all of the members
present thank you councilor councelor
frer and then councelor
Dixon thank you your worship yes I
totally agree with this this is just
bureaucracy and waste of of spending I
I'm concerned in point four you say 40%
of councils are actually proceeding down
the line that the government is going to
change what's happening I think they're
kicking a football that's flat but um
this is I've concerned I made notes down
there and I just keept writing down cost
what does this cost what does this cost
and the second of that where does the
order to get his powers from is this did
they make them up
or the order of the general counselor I
understand that but some of the
questions they seem to be answering
asking are beyond what their remit
is agreed thank you councelor uh
councilor Dixon thank you worship I
agree with everybody else because I
think that strategic plans are really on
the way out because they're not living
documents and you have this plan for 10
years and you have a government changing
as we've seen and um with three Waters
and RMA and all these other important um
policies coming out of government so I
would totally support this
recommendation and and to Steve too I
think it's a very thorough good report
very easily understood and I would like
to see us go ahead with with the
recommendation thank you councelor Dixon
uh councelor mcf another sporting
reference is
it yeah just for worship um I have to
start with saying it's obviously money
well spent to have a CEO produce this
report in line with some of the
discussions we've just had previously in
the meeting and the uh obviously the
knowledge base that's in there comes
through in that report so um the only
thing I was going to say we look at
cancellation deferral delay abolish so
what are we actually looking at do we do
we do a delaying action do we do
cancellation do we do the um deferral or
go for the Abol uh stick with what the
recommendation is to abolish it so
really try try and work out the the
recommendation that we want to look at
and the stand that we make as the
council it's it's clearly there um we're
probably at the right time the the the
environment that we're going to lead
into sits at the best position and uh
maybe that's probably just the decision
we need to make thank thank you Council
let Steve jump on a second I I'd be
interested to get the feedback of
actually leaving it open-ended if we're
going to go to our neighboring councils
and try and develop something it might
be better if we all contribute towards a
consensus to then pass on to the
minister so that there's more councilors
who are in agreement and we can we can
push it on um we can come with a I just
i' hate to come to a definite we want to
abolish it and then everyone else like
oh we just wanted to Def and then we all
get mixed messages but I yeah leave it
at a
state uh yeah thanks uh worship um I
think the preference is cancellation of
the 2024 ltp uh so there's no need to do
an ltp but with that that would mean
that just it has to be an amendment to
legislation to say recognizing the
uncertain State of Affairs you cancel
the for ltp you substitute it with an
annual plan uh I think deferral is um
unless it's booting It Forward 3 years
it's going to be problematic uh because
then you'll have ltp being prepared in
an election year or an ltp being
prepared in year one of a new Council
term and I think that would be awkward
um so my my think my recommendation for
pragmatic reasons would be a
cancellation replace with annual plan
and then uh the long-term plan uh
continues as normal in 27 and the need
for for ongoing reviews and the content
that's that's probably debate a separate
debate for later day I just think it's
actually getting in there and saying we
recognize as uncertain councils can
actually just prepare an annual plan in
two
2024 and there's no uh legislative
penalty associated with with doing that
that's that's the principal thing but
I'm hopeful that it won't spawn a
conversation going back to council
Fraser's point about the scope of audit
because what we started with in these um
hopeful days of 2006 and what what we've
now arrived at in 23 is lot night and
day in terms of the the involvement of
AIT and the cost that that keeps Rising
With
It Stephen and thank you counselor um
and and that came up um when this report
was was created of the timing is Kind of
Perfect with the future for local
government conversation as well um so
councilor frases point at Kim he added
into um those conversations around
whether yeah ltps are fit for purpose
these days and whether the audit um is
fit for purpose as
well Council gine and then
Council we' just we're probably just got
to watch though that government hasn't
formed and uh governments move very
slowly and um we have got a process in
PR place that has to be finished by mid
next year so we' and a lot of councils
have geared up themselves to do that
business business and get it done and um
we're probably just a minow we can have
have some influence but just be careful
that we don't think that it'll just
happen um because government is a very
slow process and there's lots of other
things on the agenda that'll come in
front of
us that's a that's a good point
councilor guard I I think to reassure
everyone including staff as it we will
still box on with the the ltp um until
the until central government tells us
otherwise um as I think as mentioned in
this report um we are part of the 60%
who will not trying to guess what the
law is we are sticking to the law and
continuing um to take it out in
2025 uh I'm going to let councelor mcf
go first that's right councilor hav yeah
councelor M thank you worship thank
sorry councelor hav um I'm grabbing the
ball with the horns I think we we've got
to show what we want I think I like the
report I think the canceled but is great
I'm all for it we got to show what we
want look and be first footing not back
[Music]
footing I'm going to go Council stream
because it's spoken yet and then I come
back to your CC res oh cool
fantastic uh thanks you worship um
through you look I'm going to play
devil's advocate here um we carry on
with the process so we work with the ltp
we get it to the stage where it's true
for sign off then we all vote against it
saying that this is not what we want for
the the community it's not practical
going forward what is the outcome of
such a process that is sending a very
strong message through to central
government yeah as worship just wished
my a Commissioners and uh you need to
you need to adopt an ltp uh to lawfully
set your rates and so uh what this is
suggesting is a legislative change so
that we we can get to a point in at end
of June and that won't be necessary but
we'll still have to have an annual plan
um if if the law hasn't changed by then
that's the way it is but I I think there
will be a realization that it's going to
be an Unholy mess where I mean this
three Waters reform of the last
government has got a a phase roll out so
there are entities that are going to be
some councils are going to say be waving
in theory goodbye to the three Waters
function uh as early as U next year um
and yet uh there there's leg of um
forces at play to actually remove that
and unwind it all so I think it's just
what we need to be working in parallel
here so we say well we we think we
should be canceling this ltp we'll still
work on on developing ltp uh but it's
going to create a massive confusion with
the public when we go out particularly
if there proclamations or statements
made by well-placed sources in the
government saying well this is we won't
be doing this we'll be doing something
else um and we'll be meeting the
sandwich uh because we're we're obliged
to file law but we have a sense that
that the law May well change uh so hence
the easier way is just to cancel the
need for an ltp put in place your annual
plan and then you can still lawfully
then um lever your rates and and and
crack on with things pending the clarity
of the law change because there one
thing saying you'll scrap something but
then you got to put something else in
this place um and it's taken the last
government 5 years to get where to where
it got so I don't think it'll be a 5
minute exercise but back to your point
counselor if we get to end of June and
I'm still around here and you got a
recommendation to adopt an ltp i we
begging you to to adopt it with the
greason to or not because we'll need to
get that done to actually lawfully um
set our
rates
thank you Council thank you Steve which
will make it interesting for those
councilors who accept a long-term plan
with their three Waters and for the uh
three years uh councelor hoval is there
anyone else before we do this
recommendation all yours coun I'd like
to move that the report be received and
that the council seeks cancellation of
the 2024 long-term plan with Reliance on
annual plans until 2027
thank you councelor it's a it's a good
recommendation I'm I'm more just
envisioning how it's going to go with my
other mural
peers are we are you wanting sorry is
the whole Council are we wanting to
stick on that very firmly or are we
looking to put that in as our as our
entry point and see what our neighbors
think and try and come to consensus
what's the what's the feeling from the
room second oh did you move that ah
sorry second please uh counselor rer
mcf uh open for debate do we have
a and I like it I'm just thinking about
if we're going to this meeting tomorrow
to advocate for it are we drawing a Line
in the Sand or are
we uh sorry councelor
Stringer uh three worship um why 27 is
there any particular time frame around
that I know negotiations a't High work
back but so the long-term plans are
prepared every three years in the second
year of the council's term so what it's
saying is picking up what the chief
executive says is let's park the current
one and do another one in 2027 and rely
on the annual plans until
then and um my wording of that the
council seek um leaves it open as to the
mechanisms that we use to get there and
I talked about those
before sorry just two questions one for
clarification so that means that all of
the options I was listenting at you want
advoc advocacy so mural Forum the
meeting tomorrow and a letter to the
minister that's yes and and well and as
I said it's just the council sex so the
council sex through whatever means is
available to it so there's other things
I referred
before do you mind if we put that in a
recommendation so we know exactly what
what we're we can have seeks in general
but including just so we know okay well
I'm happy to add um that the council SE
cancellation of the 2024 long-term plan
with Reliance on the annual plans until
um through through um and I would say
and or and that uh the uh Council
endorses the mayor and chief executive
um to represent the council's view at
upcoming Zone meetings and also M
forum and that uh the mayor and chief
executive pin a letter to the
minister once appointed pending yes once
appointed pending um approval by the
council I'm now just conf I think the L
should be approved by the
council so ler drafted to come back to
the next council meeting yes yep cool
did you get some sort of combination
there
uh thank you counselor the other one was
um for the chief executive what what
would an annual plan look like with all
the amount of work that we've done um I
know that we're looking at a a rates um
change and things like that what would
that look like um because I I know that
council is talking about parking it
completely and doing an annual but I'm
assuming a lot of what's being done will
be put into this annual
plan yes thank you your worship um yeah
would you would have to store with
particularly as I said my point with the
uh production of an annual plan what
I've suggested my report is that at the
moment the annual plan is voluntary as
to with you consult on it uh
particularly if it's not a major
variation from your long-term plan uh
with our rating type um proposal Chang
the way the way in which rates are uh
assessed um we would have to go out
there and consult with the people um and
that's consistent with my suggestion and
my report um I don't think we're going
to get away with long-term plans every
for no long-term plan for six years and
no obligation to consult uh I think
that's a step too far and I can rightly
can anticipate that type of push back
but if you committed to Consulting your
community and then you could uh free
yourself from some of this other
legislative and audit compliance stuff
that just bogs the whole process down
and actually doesn't actually um engage
or excite the community um um it would
be far easier um so yeah that's my
proposal annual plan but with a
mandatory obligation to consult uh
particularly if there's a decent
variation from what's in your long-term
plan thank you
Steve uh so that's moved and seconded
with those changes
cool any further questions or
comments uh councelor Reed thank you Mr
Mayor turn himself off um yeah I think
going forward that um at whatever
meetings or wherever you and the chief
executive find yourself I think we have
full confidence um in that that proposal
being put clearly in
succinctly thank you counselor yeah I
think I've got a would imagine ex we got
a pretty clear um Vision as to what the
council's wanting so I think it'll be
yeah easy to
Advocate but not easy but the messaging
should be
clear any further
comments no I will put the motion all
those in favor please say I and against
motion is carried thank you
councilors uh page 92 item 10 former
Gore landfill uh issue of abatement
notice uh was the CH like to speak to
this
one yeah thanks you worship I thought
thought it was timely to come up for
public ear uh and this issue that has
been um Brewing away now for the best
part of three months uh it had come to
us as somewhat of a surprise to be fair
it's not as if the council has been
operating under the cloak of darkness in
terms of uh capping the old landfill and
um we think it's a pretty exciting uh
project in terms of the ultimate
environmental outcome being sought uh
with planting of a native habitat um but
we have had this difference of opinion
with environment Southland about uh
whether we are currently compliant um
we're I guess fa to say disappointed
that um the abatement notice option has
been used um in the absence of any um
compelling evidence that environmental
harm has been caused we do have a
resource consent application in the
system um and we have a mediation plan
for 12th of December and it's hope that
those two events May actually ultimately
resolve the issue uh because the council
is is committing itself to that resource
coning application with um uh
willingness to uh to do undertake tests
and and provide the evidence for sort
and a comfort sort that uh it's not
actually causing harm to the environment
so this is really just for the councils
to be aware of the current state of play
um and it's obviously been paraded in a
public setting because um it's it's
arguably of high public interest
particularly the AAP notice when there
was a cease and assist with green waste
and clean fo which would really have
placed us on the back foot in terms of
trying to find an alternative uh
location for that given the high degree
of usage uh particular the public and
green waste uh that is currently being
enjoyed
thank you Steve uh questions
councelors uh councelor
Stringer you worship um yeah got a a
range of questions here where would the
fill go if um if not to the dump
there through your worship um so the the
other Alternatives um in terms of clean
fill and uh uh clean field in particular
um is to go to a transport it to uh
another site that has a consent for the
discharge of of clean fill um or to um
send it to to landfill effectively um
but as the chief executive has piloted
um this has been uh undertaken on that
site as a capping process for the closed
landfill to this point um under the
existing consent that we have in
place thank you Jason thank you
councelor
uh councelor mcel just a question for
Jason if we're not allowed to put green
waste there or clean fi how do we ever
kept the
thing
um probably I think it's it's worth
outlining here that this consent is is
pretty old um and so when when the issue
was raised by environment sethland um
the first thing uh we did is is go to
them and look at you know look let's
work together in terms of trying to
provide a a better outcome and we're
willing to look at a new consent to to
move this forward and get it really up
to standard in terms of what is expected
now with that capping process the old
consent um was developed early 2000s so
it's you know it's around 20 years old
um and probably doesn't have um great
guidance in terms of that landfill
remediation um and so it is a standard
practice to use a a clean fill um and
then uh using um green waste as a mulch
to then you know cap that and that's
quite consistently done across the
country um what we're trying to do is
formalize that through this consent
process so that we have
a that we actually do achieve that good
quality outcome that we are are after um
and and have know you and limit any uh
environmental effects as a result of
that process so you see we see it as a
um as an option um to um use that um
those
um uh items to to to finish off that
process and create a good environmental
outcome thank you uh councelor Dixon and
then councel Reed thank you worship um
this abatement notice to me is extremely
disappointing because I know that the
community are very grateful for having
free green waste and if we have to then
go ahead and pay for it to be
transported somewhere else we may have
to look at whether we can afford um the
green waste to the transfer station so I
think this is very
disappointing thank you councelor
councelor Reed thank you just a question
for Jason um how much more capping would
be required to actually complete that
currently and what would we use if those
two things the the um solid waste and
the green waste weren't
allowed uh through worship
um the the the consent really works on
um identifying those volumes I can't
recall them off the top of my head but
there's a considerable amount there um I
guess once what we sort of identified
through um probably three years ago I
think when this first came um in front
of council about 2020 following um the
2020 flood events was that the original
capping was deficient in places with the
consent um and so which required a
minimum of 500 Ms again I think for
memory um in some places it was as low
as three millimet um 300 millim and um
again so the process since then has been
to try and build up those areas and I
guess it's that's where the difference
of opinion is under between environment
South and ourselves is around whether
that's um can be undertaken as part of
that consent process and we we we
believe it is but again this was our our
goal was in to work together with
environment South and to update that
content and make sure that um you know
we're both uh happy with the processes
in place and and get the outcome that we
desire thank you counselor uh counselor
Fraser and then councelor mcf and then
councelor
St um thank you Jason and St been
through your worship I read this and I
just I nodded my head it's I I be
careful what I say here but I I struggle
to understand how they issue an
abatement
notice and then issue another abatement
notice and then don't turn up to
environment
Court what cost is that to
counil for this to happen I mean and I'm
not having to go you Jason is that from
what I read you were caught completely
by surprise by
this so I guess just to clarify that
point so we haven't been to court yet I
guess the the the court requested us to
um provide um e David on on those things
and we and a response um we did that um
environment South and chose not to which
I think they I believe they can do um
and you know that's effective of it
where it is is that result in US
achieving a stay um from the court uh
for the activity in the in the uh
interim with a then um request that we
enter a a med mediation to to try and
resolve um I guess a difference of
opinion yeah just to add to that through
your worship yeah I think the issue
really is that it was the request we
requested theant Court uh for a
stay and yes it was was surprising given
that the EV environment s was issued to
us with pretty much a ceent assist with
the media effect hence that we request
the stay pending the actual substantive
hearing on the appeal and it was
surprising given the environment South's
insistence about
immediate um um
Sensation that there wasn't
a their view wasn't represented before
the judge uh before he made his
decision thanking you uh we got
councilor mcf I thinkk you through your
worship um Jason is this same the same
system being used anywhere else in
Southland like is it a standard Pro
process
or uh through your worship I
guess there's different processes being
used um in South and my understanding
again is that inago City uses green
waste to cap its uh landfill in inago uh
they don't have clean they don't use
clean Fu there though um but I guess
through this this process and working
with um I guess a Consultants who are
supporting us you know again this this
is a common practice though used across
the country to cap um landfills and so
we're not doing anything that um is
completely outside of the norm um again
coming back to that point it's really
just I think about formalizing that and
again I think we possibly could have got
to this point without the abatement
notice would have been the uh the ideal
but that's where we are okay thanks a
lot yeah I agree with you I don't think
the abatement notice was needed but a
bit of um Talk between the two
organizations probably would have helped
a lot so thank
you thank you councelor I'm going to
councelor Phillips and councelor
Stringer thank you wor just a question
for Jason then the clean feel that um
they're describing in the in the notice
that there was large amounts was it
like cleanfill as in dirt and stuff like
that or was it they referring to
cleanville as in green
waste uh certainly both they do refer to
um to green waste and clean fill umly
being separate so clean fi was um
defined terms of um that soil or um or
other sort of uh innate material um and
green waste obviously has a different uh
different properties they're used for
different parts of that capping process
um so yeah just just distinct
clarification between those two um those
two properties
but so what was the largest group then
that they were more concerned about was
it the green waste or was it the
the reason why I asked that question is
that when we when C when the previous
staff came to us and said about the
landfill needing capped because of its
low volume uh not exceeding the the
height the correct height was that we
all accepted that the green the
cleanfill at the time was going to be
cleanfill as in the green waste when we
we we marched up the green waste was
going to be the proper re uh use to cap
the landfill as such which I questioned
at the time because of its leap problems
with green waste
but I I'm I'm concerned that
um that we had more green waste than
clean fi there and that was probably the
issue because of the Le
problem
um through you worship probably just one
point of clarification is around uh one
thing I can say so we received uh an
original abatement notice which was just
on cleanfill and then we got an upgraded
a batement notice uh a month or so after
that which included green waste on top
of that so clarification as to why that
came in and at that time uh wasn't
obviously clear to us but uh yeah there
was
certainly again just going back to that
there are some issues around um green
waste that with its Le check properties
if it's not managed correctly and that's
again another part of this process that
we want to ensure is not having an
environmental effect um and um again
that's about having the right um
mitigations in place um and that's about
that's the reason why we believed as
well that we should be looking at an
upgraded uh consent so to ensure that we
are uh not having that effect um or
those potential effects as I should say
that have been pointed
out thank you councel and thank you
Jason Neil did you still want to jump
in uh thank you your worship just in
regards to counselor
um the the question in regards to clean
waste clean fill and green waste and
going back we we've had previous
discussions around the table on that the
situation is that a lot of clean fi has
been used to fill in low lying areas the
worst thing with a landfill is if water
sits on the surface and over time it uh
leeches down through and there is a
certain area that old original capping
of the landfill which has never um been
dry basically since 2006 when it when it
was finally kept over so a lot of the um
larger clean field such as some concrete
rubber bricks Etc has been used to bring
that up to a degree and we had a
discussion today and there's no issue
with that as long as we still put a a
layer of clay over top which basically
seals it off and then it'll be finished
it off with MRA bar um or top soil so
that is now what we've been doing over
the last 2 or three years has eliminated
a lot of that soakage runoff on the area
into those um damp periers so they're
now drawing out and it appears that some
of the
leant um over the years was going to
that lowly area and um just staying
wait thank you Neil uh councelor
Stringer thank you through you worship
um understanding what Jason and NE just
said that it's an old consent and that
they're using a a process of clay for
capping um then takes away that the that
um M membrane wasn't being used if
they're worried about leeching um just
on uh do we do testing do we do our own
independent water testing to verify what
they're
seeing that
today yeah uh through your worship so we
we're required under the consent to take
uh to do monitoring at two BS um every
five years as part of that consent um
there have been uh I guess some elevated
uh
readings there but the actually the the
readings are actually Upstream of the
not Downstream of the um the closed
landf area so um the whether or not
again the impact is actually from the
landfill was again probably questionable
so it's uh there's some stuff to work
through there but yeah there would be a
a
view yeah my interpretation be water
runs downhill but yeah Council dexon um
thank you worship just a question
through you to Jason um you just said
you've done your own water testing um
and the problems are Upstream as well as
Downstream but the environment South and
data indicates that there's been an
increased Downstream of nitrogen levels
and I also wondered if that's been
increasing since 2004 because we weren't
putting green waste at that stage I
don't recall I'm not sure um but just
how what's the difference between the um
monitoring um through worship this is
actually something that sort of we've
just sort of been investigating uh more
recently and we would actually our
position is that that that the probably
I think there's an interpretation of
that data wrong so we Supply as part of
our consent monitoring the data to es
and I think that they interpreted the
data as being the downstream site rather
than the Upstream site and so there's I
just think there's actually a misread of
that that
data they they don't sample it we we
sample it so
thank you counselor we'll do one more
question I just want to keep us moving
along because we still have quite an
agenda ahead of
us one last
question no could I have a move that the
report and attachments be received and
noted uh councilor Fraser second by
councelor Stringer any further comment I
will put the motion all those in favor
please say I and against the motion is
carried
105.1 proposed Gore District plan
Council submission do you want to talk
to this one
Steve reasonably straightforward your
worship uh like I said in my report
there's usually a few minor points that
need to be corrected in a district plan
which is a big big document uh so it's
been highlighted to me there's a few um
Corrections uh notable trees uh there's
a couple that have actually no longer
exist um two or three um signs and uh
just some um alignment of rules with
development and subdivision so nothing
of any real um materiality but just
important to get it right when you got
the opportunity to uh so hence uh asking
your approval for us this to go forward
is a technical submission as distinct
from anything substantive to our own
District
plan thank you stepen I think it was
question raised by Federated farmers at
a recent meeting as uh to whether we'd
be submitting on our own District plan
um so I guess I can definitively answer
that um and if this recommendation goes
through it'll be a yes uh any questions
for the chief executive uh on this
submission uh councelor
Stringer uh three worship um just a
quick one on the um notifiable trees
um just around the process there if
trees are dying off um and we're adding
new ones to the list are we picking ones
on people's properties and that and and
do they have the ability to object to
that thank
you through your worship yes uh the
trees are deemed to be notable when they
cover mixture of private and public
property off top of my head the vast
majority tends to be in the public Arena
on Reserve Land um but there is a
Botanical assessment required you just
can't sort of just pluck it TR out of
the year as a were and say well I think
that's that's that's notable um and once
it's once it's in the plan um there is a
resource consent required and you would
have seen that recently with the power
plant property in South Gore where those
monkey puzzle trees were uh were notable
uh but they were the subject of a
resource consent decision with an
independent commissioner and they they
came down um but this is just a case of
updating our plan to to reflect reality
but no we won't be rushing around a try
plug new ones in that they've got to
pass a certain test of being
notable thank you Steve and thank you
councelor uh councelor Reed I'm happy to
move the recommendation happy to move uh
second councelor Mell uh any further
comments I will put the motion all those
in favor please say I and against the
motion is carried welcome back
counselors uh page 106 number 12 uh
Southern Regional Heritage committee
annual
report uh would either councelor
Phillips or councelor Reed like to speak
to this at
all thank you where no I'm just um happy
to take any questions uh I believe there
is some councilors uh asking the
question about why AR we sort of going
alone with the funding that we get um
and I believe it may be prudent in
perhaps that we have a you know a little
bit of a discussion sometime at a
council about how we how the money SP
where it's SP and so far so just uh hope
you to answer any
questions thank you counc um yes I was
one of those councils wanting to ask
some questions of the CFO but it appears
she's not here so it might be a better
conversation uh for when she is
available um I'll open the floor though
to any questions
know I guess for the Insight of um other
counselors uh and I guess the public too
is uh just
around uh the grants the grants that we
give um that we I believe is a targeted
rate um and just how that works it works
in a bit of a by the looks it's a bit of
a roundabout so we give over
237k uh and then we get back just under
200k so um I guess my question for the
CFO was kind of how does that process
work um and I'm guessing no one here
knows that
answer no okay but that's something can
be asked um out of out of council uh any
further questions on on this one
councilor G I just noticed the auditing
cost on that organization nearly trebled
I think uh so you may have to look at
how the organization is actually set up
in the future future may have to come
under a council and try and cut out some
of that audit cost um there is some
rather large cost just to run an
organization and and if a keeps trebling
every year you'll definitely have to
look at
it thank you councelor gine uh yeah and
that's what I want to ask about the
roundabout is whether that money then
gets audited twice because it seems like
an expensive process for this committee
to audit it and then for us to audit it
or I believe it sits with in the Carle
City Council the books is that right
Council read yeah so for them to order
then for it to yeah it sounds
complicated um but it's something that
see if I will be able to answer I'm
sure uh Council THS yeah thank you
worship perhaps then uh it would be
prent for us then to have a bit like we
just had with um Great South have a bit
of discussion about how they operate um
how the money gets spent out how it's
allocated and so forth and
um and we'll have have employee gym here
at the present would it be the best
idea thank you councel I think it's
actually a great idea um considering the
the money we give great South and the
targeted rate for this are relatively
similar in um funds it would be good to
have the CFI in that compensation for
both so I can see the chief executive
jotting that down would you like there's
a recommendation or you happy to note
that cool uh in that case uh could I
have a mover that the annual report the
Southern Regional Heritage Comm be
received councelor read second buy
councelor Phillips any further questions
on this
report I will put the motion all those
in favor please say I and against the
motion is carried uh
12513 summary of me Forum
meeting uh unless council is on not I
don't think you weren't there for that
one were you at the housing yeah um
that's cool
uh I guess just the the continuing
conversation about um the locality
boundaries
um we this was a while ago I'm trying to
recall um we
were asked by tat water to start having
a conversation about whether everyone
could agree on some of the the
boundaries um in particular the hooki
locality we're we're lucky and we're the
Prototype so um we're here the all there
um and they're already delivering some
good outcomes there um but for us it's a
bit tricky cuz the huoi locality has its
prototypes um reaches into Southland
district and also CLA um so I believe at
that meeting um we decided it was
actually best for that to go to a Zone
meeting where cluther can be in the room
uh rather than us agreeing with
Southland as to where the borders should
be uh but not not cluther so it's an
ongoing conversation um and hopefully a
peaceful
one uh the
other the other from my recollection was
the presentation from from May Clark um
which they had basically put together on
request of um I believe it was a
national party kind of a list of wants
for the city um it was a conversation
with both myself and Rob from
SDC uh if we could also create a similar
document um and then all go to
Wellington together which um mayor Clark
was was comfortable with um and I
believe the regional ass came out of
that as well which I think Great South
has provided as councils would have seen
so that's all being worked in the in the
background so that we have a position
that we can um take to Wellington rather
than just one Council going off and
asking for things we can all all go
together hopefully Council h i I can
give an update in terms of the regional
ask U document uh in that I put together
um something on behalf of of council um
asking the incoming government as our
top priority to give funding to enable
us to comply with the national drinking
water standards by providing um funding
for a pipe across the river and um
replacement of the reservoir um in um
North cor um and also as a second um
proposal um asking for a relatively um
modest uh uh amount in the hundreds of
thousands of dollars um to do a survey
of gravel supplies that may be suitable
for um use by the territorial
authorities um gravel is becoming a uh
ins short supply um for our works or
good quality gravel and the ownership
under the um current regimes where um
they tend to be um dominating by one or
two firms and possibly has an impact on
the price that we pay at the end of the
day so if the um councils were able to
act together and it may even be
appropriate for cluther to be part of
that um there's an opportunity of
identifying gravel supplies that
possibly the councils themselves um
should look at being the owners um so
that's that's gone off even if it isn't
accepted by government um it would be a
useful thing to have discussed at the
mural Forum um to see if we can work
together with the other councils to
ensure that the money we do spend on our
gravel supplies and on roading is um
spent wisely and it's in the interest of
government to see that happen too um
because if we can get gravel cheaper um
then the money we given by government
goes
further thank you Council so yeah that
that document's being worked I think
there's some stuff around housing in
there as well so that will come to
fruition I'm sure will come to a public
meeting um in the near future so that
our community can uh indulge as well do
we have any any questions on those
minutes nope could I please have a move
that they be
received councilor mcon Now seconded by
councelor Phillips I will put the motion
all those in favor please say I and
against the motion is carried 14 minutes
of the matota community board
meeting page 128 did Neil want to speak
to these at all sorry Council Phillips
um thank you worship now the community
board chair myself are happy to answer
any questions that any councilors
may want
have uh I was going to ask muray for a
question but he's not here so I will say
his exciting news for another time uh
Jason did you want to come
in what's the question for Mario might
have an answer for it if it's around the
SS are you going to steal his
[Laughter]
Thunder yeah go for it just just just an
update uh so we've got um one of the
things holding up the signs has been the
deed of Grant from kiwi rail so we have
had some movement on there and it's
um uh we're aware that it's going to be
issued this week um so from there we um
requested with uh with McDonald's to
then hopefully get those uh signs in
place um provided that all comes through
prior to Christmas so that's the latest
and
greatest thank you Jason um and I think
it was a promise uh by the community
board or someone that it would be by
Christmas so yeah
yeah any further questions thank you for
that update Jason any further questions
I believe nille is holding a party at
the sign um once it's in as
well too right and I'll be wearing a
Sandy
hat um Ju Just for the interest of um
the councilors who moved the petition
about the bus services to the community
board you'll see by the minutes that the
pan Community War are going to work
through the the issue and report back
later on
so thank you
councelor any further
questions uh nope uh could I have move
that the minutes of the meeting held on
the 30th of October 2023 be received
councelor Stringer seconded by councelor
mcf I will put the motion all those in
favor please say I
and against the motion is carried number
15 page 134 minutes of the sport New
Zealand rural trust fund committee
meeting would anyone like to speak to
this at
all Council M now was a very short
meeting we only had one application and
that was approved so I'll move that the
report be received or is that what we're
going to
do move that am minutes be
received thank you councilor second by
the guine any further questions I will
put the motion all those in favor please
say I and against the motion is carried
uh the Urgent late business is item 16
find um
here uh hope I've got everything in the
report um was pretty frantic putting it
together today
um just I guess want to express um spent
a lot of time working with the the
committee on this agenda um pretty proud
of how it's turned out out uh the
registrations of closed we' we've sold
out for for the event um with with
members all across the country going um
so it's yeah pretty pretty exciting to
to see um the increase in young elected
members across across the
board I'll give councils a few minutes
to read through it um and then Happy
answer
questions
councelor Phillips you want to kick us
off thank you I'm just saying thinking
I'm just pity I'm not a bit
younger thank you counselor and uh
councelor Phillips didn't mention as I W
past about the cocktail function um if I
am incing I won't be able to drink the
cocktail function unfortunately um and
we'll be advising young members not to
either considering we'll be having a
poor F at whong the next day probably
not the thing you should show to hung
over I'd
imagine uh Council H thank you your
worship and thank you for bringing this
um report forward um I felt that the um
way that we have set up the mural um
funds and I don't call it a budget
because I don't believe there is a
budget um is is that this actually sits
outside because it's not directly
related to your role as me it's more as
as a young elected member and I thought
it was appropriate and I'm I'm sure
Council McKenzie will agree that we
follow the correct process um I I do
Wonder though um that um as as part of
this whether there shouldn't be an
additional an additional
recommendation um to the effect that um
at at um the earliest convenience that a
budget be provided for elected members
travel and training and that that may be
the longterm plan if we long-term plans
or maybe some other um basis um because
there's conferences that come up during
the year training opportunities that
come up and we're in a a bit of a um uh
blind spot in terms of what are we able
to go to so not only should there be a
budget but there should be some criteria
set out uh in in terms of what's
appropriate for us to attend so I see
this this report is coming forward
giving approval um for what no doubt
looks like a a worthwhile um exercise um
but I really just want to get some
structure moving forward so that we've
got certainty and um both over the
monies and what's
appropriate thank
you thank you counselor um and I'd
welcome that as well I think I've had
offline conversations with a number of
counselors as well about PD budgets so
personal development budgets um
I'm not aware that we have them at this
this Council um other councils do um so
a lot of the other young elected members
have dipped into their their PD budgets
um so they get a certain allocation for
that trianium that they're allowed to
use for training and other things and
and have those Provisions um and then
there's obviously mural budgets as well
so will you just for clarification
Council were you looking for a
conversation around PD budgets and also
mural budget or you wanting more of a
conversation around
travel what so which which rot or
encompassing it
all um my my focus was was really on the
um travel and and training for us all um
but in the absence of a mural budget as
such um I think that's a worthwhile
thing to explore
yeah yeah we can have we can have the
discussion in LTV Workshop about both
yeah that's easy enough is
some so there there is some money set
aside for for the m and CH travel I
believe confence
team uh thank you councelor councelor
Paul
mcf through your worship look I'm just
looking at it from um the a r p
perspective of the value for our
district um of this event or an event
similar to it and I think we've been
striving in the back to the basics comes
back to me in vanity projects keeps
coming back in my head I just need to
know from you or whoever is going to be
is the value to our
district yeah fair question I I
personally think the agenda that we put
together is an exceptional training
opportunity um it's three days
jam-packed with um cultural training um
we're going to hear from some amazing
speakers across the board um and I'm
looking to bring that knowledge back and
share it um with with the council
um yes it it obviously is is quite a
price tag but that includes
accommodation um some uh think lunches
and bits and pieces uh and also the
entire conference so um we have tried to
keep that down I think that is also
subsidized slightly by lgnz and sponsors
too um so there's a whole lot of
learnings in those three days that we're
trying to package up and and I would be
happy to um bring back to the council um
cultural competency is something that
we've been training in as well so I'm
hoping to bring bring back those
learnings from from Whitey on what those
are and share those
experiences thank you we'll look forward
to hearing all the wonderful knowledge
um of of what you bring back thank you
counselor councelor Richard
mcf yes thank you worship um I won't go
through too much here um obviously it'd
be nice to have an old elected members
Hy program at some stage
but might have to wait might have to
wait um just confirming uh and it's more
operational the in this time frame that
you're away there doesn't tie in to any
of our CEO matters CEO panel matters or
anything like that I'm not sure I want
to confirm that we're not CU we're we're
running to the end of the year and I
know we're very very tight and that uh
there's no availability or any issues
there other than that um yeah it looks a
fine timetable and I will look forward
to your report back to us and what you
what your learnings
are thank than you counselor um yes uh
Nikki has done a absolutely fabulous job
um working around my schedule not only
for oh sorry all of our schedules
actually not just for this event but
also how full all of our calendars come
into um the end of the year uh see
recruitment in the Christmas period um
is is difficult in terms of time frames
to say the least um but we have stuck to
track um as it as it's been laid out so
so yes I won't interrupt that
process
any further
questions I just like to
move that we um accept this and pay for
your
um is it $900 something doll
it and if is to go to this conference
thank you councelor does that include
the recommendations by Council hovell as
well uh yes it does yeah well they well
defined enough for you
Susan Co happy to Second
Council yep uh we'll continue having the
conversation councelor
Stringer s worship um don't realize kir
K had a airport I'm just wondering if
it's like GS one can you let us know
when you flying
please
uh yeah neither did I I was actually
planning on flying to Orland and and
driving up but um yeah I was told
there's an airport exactly where we're
going so that works
too any further questions
comments I will put the motion all those
in favor please say I and against motion
is carried thank you very much
counselors that brings us to the end of
the in public meeting I will just
quickly close with the kutak here and
then we will have
a 5 minute break yeah 10 10 10 minute
break cool uh
F
everyone